we're facing a lot of problems as a
nation record high inflation Rising
crime food shortages Chinese spy planes
and the prospect of World War III but
one issue rises above all those threats
and President Biden addressed it last
night during the State of the Union I
speak of course about hotel resort fees
my Administration is also taking on junk
fees those hidden surcharges too many
companies use to make you pay more we're
going to ban surprise Resort fees that
hotels charge an honored Bill most fees
can cost up to 90 a night at hotels that
aren't even Resorts and will prohibit
Airlines from charging 50 round trip for
family just to be able to sit together
baggies fees are bad enough Airlines
can't treat your child like a piece of
baggage for too long
workers have been getting stiffed but
not anymore
we're getting we're beginning to restore
the Dignity of work
for example 30 million workers have to
sign non-compete agreements
with the jobs they take 30 million
so a cashier
at a burger place can't walk across town
and take the same job at another burger
place and make a few bucks more but not
anymore
for Banning those agreements so
companies have to compete for workers
and pay them what they're worth
people can't afford eggs
the cost of eggs Rose 60 last year much
more than that in some places Joe Biden
hasn't fixed any of the things he said
he'd fixed in almost every single case
he's made those problems worse but hey
he says he's going to try really hard to
reduce Resort fees and
luggage fees and
the burden of non-compete clauses in the
Apparently c-suite level contracts of
fast food workers
he can't do anything that would actually
improve your life but he promises to do
some minor things that probably won't
affect your life very much you've got
Joe's word on that and when has Joe
Biden ever lied to you I'm Michael
Knowles this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
oh
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from berserker117
who says anyone else notice how the red
color theme of the Grammy Awards matched
the color of Biden's speech last night
is a red no the problem is he's he's not
even a red
he's not he's certainly not a
conservative he's not a commie he's just
a stale old tired establishment liberal
so it seems like the worst of all
possible worlds
if you were a Kami at least he'd have a
vision it would be an evil Vision but
he'd have a vision
here the vision is I'm not going to do
anything to fix anything it's all
falling apart
but you guys ever notice those Resort
fees
you ever notice that it's a Tara that's
awful one way one way when you get stuck
with a fee that you don't know how
you're going to pay for one way you
could do it is if you have your wealth
Diversified into really stable
Investments such as gold that's why you
got to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 the U.S blew
through
31.4 trillion dollars in its debt
ceiling last month and still the White
House refuses to reduce spending if
you're worried about the future of this
nation's economy you need to consider
diversifying into gold with Birch gold
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals text Knowles right now to 98 98
98 to claim your free info kit on gold
and then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists I have really enjoyed
investing in Precious Metals in my life
I think it's served me very well with an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings and you will see why
conservatives tend to like investing in
precious metals and gold specifically
text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 and
protect yourself with gold today that is
Knowles to 98 98 98. I can't get over
the resort fees that was to me that was
the highlight of the night because it
wasn't even just that he picked this
really stupid issue to focus on amid all
of the historic problems that we have
it's that he really thought this would
resonate when he leaned into the
microphone so we're going to stop those
Resort fees at hotels that sometimes
aren't even resorts
who is he speaking to
do you remember when the Democrats were
the party of The Working Man Republicans
were the party of Rich Uncle petting
bags the plutocrat and now the biggest
issue and at the time of greatest
economic economic turmoil since at least
2008.
but the Democrats are focusing on is
Resorts and air and airplane
inconveniences you know when you're jet
setting around the world to go to your
Resorts sometimes you have to pay an
extra 50 bucks to check your bag well
we're gonna put an end to that
and we're gonna put an end to
non-compete agreements which
99.9 of the time only affect High
earning c-suite level and upper
management level workers and he's
pretending that it's Burger flippers who
have to sign non-competes give me a
break I'm not going to subject you to
the rest of the speech
and I'm not even one of those
conservatives who hates the State of the
Union per se you know Ben frequently
says it's monarchical garbage and he
hates every state of the union I I don't
mind it I like that there's this one
event every year in our politics that
unifies both houses of Congress and both
parties and we all have to go and
pretend that we like the president or at
least that we're semi-unified and it
draws a lot of public attention to our
political system it's got Grandeur it's
somewhat uplifting compared to the rest
of our politics but last night was just
bad
it was just a bad one the cleverest part
of the night was in the very beginning
Joe Biden opened up the speech by
congratulating Kevin McCarthy on
becoming speaker this was a dig at
the Republicans it was a it was a stab
in the back to McCarthy because he he
knows that if he Joe Biden Praises Kevin
McCarthy that's going to hurt Kevin
McCarthy with Republicans and it was a
it was a real twisting of the knife to
Maga because Maga and the more
conservative members of Congress opposed
Kevin McCarthy so it was a way to just
put a little wedge in there with the
Republicans was cleverly done Joe Biden
did the same thing to Mitch McConnell
Mitch we've known each other forever
looking forward to working with you it
was just another way to to divide the
Senate Republican leader from from his
base another funny moment of the night
was when Joe Biden referred to his
achievement of near record unemployment
for blacks and Hispanics that's an
important phrase is near record
unemployment for blacks and Hispanics
right
who had the record unemployment
who which president starts with the T
ends with a rump achieved the record
unemployment oh you can't say that so he
says near record unemployment so it's
just he's basically saying Trump did a
great job on Black and Hispanic
unemployment and I haven't completely
ruined it in in just a few years then uh
Joe Biden focused on The Talk
this is another ridiculous issue uh this
is this line allegedly that black
parents have to have with black children
to say you know listen police are going
to kill you if because you're a black
person so you've got to be extra super
special respectful to the police and
you've got to play by a different set of
rules with the police than white people
do it's not true it's not true they say
this is a talk white student white white
parents never need to have with their
children it's not true
okay when I was learning how to drive I
was taught if a cop pulls you over you
stay perfectly still hands on the 10 and
the two on the wheel yes sir no sir yes
officer no officer everybody gets that
talk every and unfortunately a lot of
people who don't get that talk are the
ones who end up in the situations that
are provocative with the police
it's not not a racial thing and he did
it with with uh Tyree Nichols the
parents of Tyree Nichols who was killed
exclusively by black cops but still
trying to raise bait that's part of
every single Democrat State of the Union
then the biggest Applause line of the
night was when Joe Biden said we need to
kill a lot more babies in the country
and he would work to protect abortion
and federal law that was that was the
moment that all of those
demonically obsessed or possessed
Democrats stood up there and cheered
like a bunch of hyenas and then there
was another great line he says name me a
world leader who would change places
with Xi Jinping the answer to which is
most of them would because Xi Jinping is
a very powerful leader on the world
stage and he's currently eating Joe
Biden's lunch
and then the final little bit of unity
we got from the state of the union was
when Joe Biden tried to tie the Paul
Pelosi attack by a polygamous lunatic
illegal alien vagrant in San Francisco a
city that hasn't been governed by
Republicans since the Stone Age it tried
to tie that to
January 6th the very worst day
and three of the world and and he he did
it in a way that was actually very very
clunky and is of course preposterous
that was the whole speech
you didn't if you didn't watch it you
didn't miss very much the Republicans
had a response they actually had more
than one response and the response was
given by Sarah Sanders this is the
hardest job in politics it never helps
people's careers but I gotta tell you I
thought Sarah having been given this
terrible job I thought Sarah did a
phenomenal job at the the State of the
Union response
while you read the consequences of their
failures the Biden Administration seems
more interested in woke fantasies than
the hard reality Americans face every
day
most Americans simply want to live their
lives in Freedom and peace
but we are under attack in a left-wing
culture War we didn't start and never
wanted to fight
every day we are told we must partake in
their rituals salute their flags and
worship their false Idols all while big
government colludes with big Tech to
strip away the most American thing there
is
your freedom of speech
it's not normal
crazy and it's wrong
make no mistake
Republicans will not surrender this
fight
we will lead with courage and do what's
right not what's politically correct or
convenient
love it I think Sarah is terrific I
thought she was one of the best press
secretaries we've had in American
history I think she's doing a great job
down there as governor of Arkansas what
does she do take note squishy
Republicans what does she do
she doesn't give some Anodyne speech
about how we just need to deregulate
just deregulate
get the government out of our lives
we're come on the left is insane we're
the same people no she said we're in a
culture War
we're in a culture war that we didn't
start the left started it
the left started the culture war and
then what do they say they always say
well who cares about the transgender
bathrooms who cares about what your kids
are being taught in school gay porn in
the elementary school library who cares
who cares who cares who cares
you guys care
the libs care
why do you care because it matters maybe
the conservatives should care too I
thought Sarah did a bang-up job her
presentation was great didn't seem angry
didn't seem weak she just seemed on the
money she had a very Clear Vision
but unfortunately
that very clear Vision which has worked
out very well in Virginia culture War
one is the Virginia governorship worked
out very well in Florida
culture work gave us the victories in
Florida and and Ron DeSantis is now one
of the leading Republican candidates for
president 2024. hasn't even declared
that he's running
but the Republicans gave another speech
and it was not all that culturally
conservative in fact it was not even in
English when things irritate me in
politics I know I need to calm down
practice patients
kiss it up as as people used to say
one great way to do that is with hallow
right now go to hallow.com Knowles seems
like for Lent this year the libs are
giving up their morals and any common
sense you and I are going to combat that
with a solid foundation in our faith
values and fasting Ash Wednesday is
coming up on February 22nd there is no
better time than now to start building a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
with hallow hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app and the number one
Catholic app in the world pray every
single day leading up to Easter with
world famous Catholics and Protestants
alike Jim Caviezel father Mike Schmitz
even Mark Wahlberg dive deep into
scripture and the second most read
Christian book of all time the imitation
of Christ you will learn how to become a
better individual in spite of today's
broken world through prayer fasting and
giving hallow will help guide you on
your journey to become more like Christ
download Hello at hello.com Knowles and
get an exclusive three months for free
which will carry you through lent and
Easter that is three months free
absolutely free at hello.com Knowles
the Republicans gave
a second state of the union response
this one in Spanish I'm pleased to say
that at least one of the three state of
the union addresses last night was in
English
we had a congressman Juan Cisco Money he
spoke Spanish Joe Biden spoke gibberish
Sarah Sanders at least spoke some
English a Juan ciscomani had this to say
foreign
we've made a compromiso
commitment to America
commitment to every American that
prioritizes a strong economy a secure
Nation future based on freedom
that's the compromise Estados unidos
that the Republicans are offering us you
know what come from miso I would like
that we can serve anything in this
country that we can serve anything
that that compromiso would be really
nice to me
if we could conserve the women's
bathroom that would be that'd be a nice
thing to conserve Republicans
conservatives failed to do that
if we could conserve the English
language the language that we're
supposed to speak as a nation that would
be good I'd sign up for that compromiso
but I guess it wouldn't be a compromiso
it would be
a pledge a promise a commitment a vision
it would be even remotely conservative
my problem here is not with one Cisco
Money as some people I think have
misinterpreted my views on this rather
important subject
once this comani seems great he's a
newcomer to politics so we don't really
know how conservative he is where he
falls but if you just look at his policy
positions if you look at the way he ran
his campaign
he seems quite conservative and frankly
more importantly in many ways he clearly
leads a conservative life he's married
he has six kids great very admirable
stuff he looks the part
he behaves the part but he doesn't quite
sound the part
of conservatism because this is The
American Nation
and here in America we're supposed to
speak English
and so you can give the most eloquent
beautiful speech in the world about
cutting taxes and preserving freedom in
the American dream and securing the
nation if you're giving it in a foreign
language
during a major national political event
that is supposed to unify us as a nation
that is not conservative that's the
opposite of conservative and it's deeply
offensive it makes a mockery of our
tradition and the Very idea that we are
one nation
we have nothing that unifies Us in this
country
we used to have more that unified us we
don't have that anymore
and in some cases the loss of that Unity
was intentional and was done with with
the best of very best of intentions and
comes out of some of the historical
circumstances of the United States
but it is just a matter of historical
fact that Nations
traditionally can be unified by religion
we no longer are unified that way can be
unified by race we used to be much more
unified that way but there were always
racial differences in America just from
the fact that the Dutch came over then
you had the the English come over and
I'm just talking about New York right
there and there were already Native
Americans there in New York I was
largely settled by the English in the
United States but you did have people
from Spain in the southeast of the
United States you had a whole you have a
bunch of Irish immigrants some Italian
immigrants yet black slaves obviously so
it was always uh racially more
complicated even though it was
predominantly white but certainly in the
age of mass migration there's no no uh
racial Unity whatsoever there used to be
some kind of ideological Unity even as
the religious unity of the country
transformed and started to wane you at
least had ideological Unity the idea of
the Civic religion we all venerated the
same kinds of symbols and statues and
figures that's gone now we're knocking
down figures of the statues is rather of
the founding fathers and we're
protesting the the Star-Spangled Banner
and the the symbol of the country itself
all of that is gone we don't even share
an epistemology anymore we we can't even
agree on how to know anything at all
the the most basic thing we could still
share and have together is language is
the way that we speak
and and it's the conservatives who take
that away it's very very offensive now
I've heard one good objection to this
point of view
this is an objection from uh a great
Twitter account TK Dylan who made this
point he said Michael you're
misunderstanding this because you're
thinking of America as a nation and
America is not a nation if America ever
was a nation it certainly is not a
nation any longer you've got to
recognize that the country is
essentially just like an Empire right
now and we're governing this country not
as George Washington would govern a
nation we're governing this country like
the habsburgs would have ruled the
austro-hungarian Empire or something
like that we've got different Pockets
with different religions different
cultural backgrounds different this
different that and so we've just got to
speak to those different Pockets uh
and speak into their differences and
recognize there is no such thing as
National Unity I I don't want to give up
the idea
that we are an American Nation I don't
want to give up the idea that we
actually have something in common from
sea to shining sea I don't want to give
up the idea that despite the differences
between the states and the various
peoples who who constitute the states
that we actually are out of many one I
I'm not ready to give up that idea
but if even the freaking conservatives
are now giving their state of the union
responses in foreign languages maybe I'm
the last one maybe I'm the last one who
is holding out some hope for a loribus
Unum speaking of Republicans with
Hispanic last names
Ron DeSantis is getting hammered by
Donald Trump uh Donald Trump has been
really increasing the attacks in recent
days he's no longer just
talking about Ron Des sanctimonius he's
now mocking DeSantis for for
crying as he begged for his endorsement
Ron DeSantis got elected because of me
you remember he had nothing he was dead
he was leaving the race he came over and
he begged me begged me for an
endorsement he was getting ready to drop
out I gave him endorsement and as soon
as I gave that endorsement in fact I
said you're gonna have a hard time he's
running against Adam Putnam the
Commissioner of Agriculture who had a
massive lady he's been running for eight
years while he was commissioner he had
40 million dollars in cash I believe it
was 40 and he was up in Nepal massively
by you know but not catchable not even
catchable he said if you endorse me I'll
win and there were tears coming down
from his eyes
he said if you endorse me I'll win I'll
say you know what Ron Ron was one of 150
people that was on television
there were tears coming down from his
eyes this reminds me of trump talking
about Megyn Kelly you remember he said
oh there was there was blood coming at
everywhere I don't know I think that was
the line he said or the oh you know
you've got Little Marco there Little
Marco is sweating he's always he's got
he's drinking water he's sweating I
don't know what it is with Little Marco
this is how Donald Trump Brands his
opponents when he does it well the way
that he does it is he focuses on
physical attributes
well it's it's Little Marco oh it's j
you see John Kasich the way he eats it's
disgusting you never saw anything so
disgusting in your life oh this woman
that woman big fat slob you ever look at
that oh yeah Ronnie had tears in his
eyes uh Trump is a a very Vivid
uh describer of his opponents and and he
paints those pictures with with words
but he's he's really painting you an
image here that's what he's doing to
DeSantis he's now also calling DeSantis
a groomer saying that when DeSantis was
a teacher he would go around and get
cozy with the high school girls and
drink with them and
and everyone's very upset about this
it's the way it goes guys this is the
this is what it is if you're going to
run against Donald Trump
and frankly I'm glad for it if you're
going to run for president you need a
thick skin you need to be able to work
through lots of difficult attacks Trump
said that Ted Cruz's dad murdered JFK
okay so if you think that Ron DeSantis
who's a big tough guy all right that he
can't handle some some of these attacks
from from Donald Trump and he's not
going to make it very far in the
presidential race this is primary
politics but it shouldn't be this way
why is Trump doing this is this is what
this is what Trump has to do to give
himself the best chance of getting the
nomination
and DeSantis isn't punching back because
that's what Rhonda Santos has to do to
give himself the best chance of winning
the nomination these are Big Boys we're
16 months out from the RNC it's okay
it's okay all right
we have to be prepared for an intense
primary you need to be prepared in case
Supply chains go down and you can't
access your medicine that's why you got
to go check out Jace medical right now
go to Jace medical
j-a-s-e-medical.com enter code Knowles
if the past couple years has taught you
anything at all it is that in a crisis
like a global pandemic or a natural
disaster even the basics can be hard to
come by
you've got to be prepared for anything
Jace medical is here to help Jace
medical helps you get a long-term supply
of prescription meds
their mission is to empower you to be
better medically prepared a great way to
start preparing is with the Jace case a
pack of five different courses of
antibiotics that you can use to treat a
whole host of bacterial illnesses basic
stuff UTIs respiratory infections
sinusitis skin infections and more all
you have to do is fill out a simple
online form and in some cases jump on a
call with one of their board certified
positions from there you can ask your
physician at treatment related questions
on an ongoing basis I'll make this
really blunt okay if China invades
Taiwan
the supply chain is getting cut off if
certain very possible really maybe
likely events happen in the world supply
chain is going to be seriously affected
get that peace of mind that even in the
worst case you have got a Jace case I
want you to be prepared for anything be
like the Knowles family go to
jacemedical.com enter code Knowles at
checkout for a discount on your order
that is jacemedical.com promo code
Knowles
speaking of Ron DeSantis
Rhonda santis he's making enemies
he's making enemies over there at The
View
Whoopi Goldberg is furious specifically
at Ron DeSantis she calls him a freak
who's trying to rewrite history
there is not America's history without
these brown and black people that's what
I want to hear him say tonight because
one of the things that he knows is he
knows that that women in particular have
worked and particularly Brown women have
worked their butts off to make sure that
he became the president and I need to
hear him say this bonehead
in Florida and in Texas is out of step
with America yeah he's out of step with
who we are as a nation because there is
no Nation without us
and I need I need to hear him say that
as my president yes I need to know that
he's aware that there are freaks out
there who are trying to change history
and he's not going to stand for it
that's what I want from you Joe
at least for that last part
fact check true there are freaks out
there who are trying to change and
rewrite history
it's not the freaks that Whoopi's
talking about but there are freaks
trying to do that in fact the most
prominent example of this in recent
years was called the 1619 project it was
a project of the New York Times that the
New York Times put millions and millions
of dollars into promoting it's now made
its way into schools it was written by
Nicole
was it Nicole Hannah Jones I think is
her name Nicole Hannah Jones whose
Central thesis the whole thesis of the
project was that a motivating the the
motivating factor for the American
Revolution was to preserve slavery and
so the the true date of America's
founding is not 1620 when the pilgrims
arrive on the Mayflower it's not
1776 when the revolution kicks off no
it's 1619 when the first slave ships
arrived on the East Coast
the central thesis was proven wrong it
was debunked it wasn't even just
debunked by those of us on the right it
was debunked by left-wing academic
historians who said that this woman who
was setting out to rewrite history was
just making it up it was so thoroughly
debunked that the New York Times quietly
had to rewrite the thesis because not
even the New York Times which lies all
the time could defend it
that's who is rewriting history
the rewriting of history that we are
getting constantly
from the left almost exclusively from
the left and so what Ron DeSantis is
saying is we don't want those freaks
rewriting history Whoopi Whoopi you
should be thrilled the freaks who are
trying to rewrite history they're being
kicked out of the classrooms that's good
you should thank Ron DeSantis if Whoopi
Goldberg had read any history ever in
her life which I am skeptical
I'm skeptical of that Prospect speaking
of the power of historical narrative
because this is what it's about when
when
when the people who dismiss the culture
wars they say oh who cares who cares
about some stupid story in the New York
Times that then goes into some high
school and then the kids learn it in
their class it doesn't who what what
does that matter
who cares the left cares that's why the
left is trying to rewrite history and
the left is trying to rewrite history
because if you control the past you
control the future
if you control the past
and you promote a history that is true
that is our country is basically a good
place and we have an obligation to love
our country because patriotism is an
extension of filial piety and America is
an expression of Western civilization
and Western Civilization is a good thing
and it's actually the greatest
civilization ever in the world and it's
animated by a good and True Religion
called Christianity and it's created the
most beautiful works of art the greatest
achievements that we've ever seen From
Any Human Society ever if you if you
have that view that is going to affect
the way that you interact with your
country today right now in the present
and it's going to affect the country
that you were going to have into the
future if on the other hand you have a
bunch of freaks in Whoopi Goldberg's
terms go in and rewrite history and say
actually America is the most evil place
ever and actually Western Civilization
they never did anything good they only
did bad stuff they're just colonizers
and imperialists and all the good good
stuff they ever got they just stole it
anyway and it's all built on slave labor
in the west actually the West is
responsible for slavery even though the
West has practiced slavery less than any
other civilization ever in the world and
today is the only part of the world that
has actually abolished slavery yet no
the West is responsible for that's why
it's so evil and oppressive and terrible
well that's going to affect the way you
you interact with your society today
it's going to determine the sort of
society that you're gonna have in the
future because you're going to hate the
society that you've currently got and
you don't want to tear down the best
stuff about it that's that's why people
fight over history that's why the
conservatives need to stand firm that's
why Rhonda santis going in and and Glenn
young can going in and other people who
are fighting this academic battle right
now
that's why it matters when they go in
and they say no we're not going to teach
our students this crap because
classrooms are like crystal balls and
when you look into a classroom you were
seeing your country 20 years into the
future seven or eight years ago
conservatives love to say oh these
snowflakes on the college campuses these
woke snowflakes just wait till they get
to the real world that's going to be a
big surprise for them
no the woke people and the little
snowflakes
were smarter about this issue because
they knew that they were going to get
into the real world and they were just
going to change the world
and and change the way that we all had
to accommodate them they were going to
demand that we Bend our perceptions to
their absurd Wills
they want the classroom really was a
crystal ball
you see this playing out right now in
basic crime stories this is a really
really
disturbing a story I was reading it at
the daily wire
bicycling doctor allegedly murdered by
man who reportedly muttered about white
privilege California emergency room
doctor out for a ride on his mountain
bike was allegedly murdered Wednesday by
a man who police had struck him from
behind with his vehicle then jumped out
and repeatedly stabbed him while
according to a witness to crying white
privilege
this would be funny if it weren't so sad
but but think about the absurdity of
this
a guy is driving along I guess it was a
black guy who's driving along and
presumably wasn't a white guy although
these days I don't know the white
Liberals are so self-hating I guess it
could have been but but I assume it was
not a white guy he's driving along he
sees a white guy
he is enraged I imagine not merely by
the color of the guy's skin though I
suppose it could have been that but
maybe he's enraged by the bicyclist
riding too slowly maybe he's enraged by
the fact that this guy gets to go on a
bike ride while he's got to be driving
and he's he's working or something
whatever enraged him he gets out of he
hits the guy gets out of the car and
just starts stabbing this man to death
while claiming to be the victim himself
while claiming that the man that he is
murdering
is he's the oppressor
he's got all of the privilege
and he the murderer he is the oppressed
one
he's the one who doesn't have is he
stabbing this man since it's California
the guy's stabbing him will probably get
off of the warning
vehicle approach to cyclist at an
intersection
drove around the victim after hitting
him exited the vehicle went back and
just continued to assault the victim
because of white privilege
if you believe if you believe that if
you believe what you are taught in
schools and by the media and by the
government and everywhere in the pop
culture and by the diversity training at
your office and by everything in the
culture if you believe that white people
really are not only evil but the source
of all the evil in society the very
reason that Society is broken because
the the true evil that pervades our
country is whiteness structural
whiteness that we have to abolish then
because ideas have consequences you
might take it into your own hands to
abolish that whiteness by abolishing the
life of the white person that you run
into and you would feel totally
justified
if you are
not particularly intelligent as I can't
imagine this murderer is if you are not
particularly thoughtful or well educated
you could really believe that as you're
murdering someone you say wow I'm really
I'm doing the right thing
wow I stopped this guy from oppressing
me with his nice private bicycle ride
that's the consequence of critical race
Theory that's the consequence of the
critical studies departments in
universities and high schools now that
tell you that America is an evil country
and white people in particular are the
problem
and if you're not white you're justified
in doing whatever you want
to
victimize the alleged oppressors that's
the consequence of it
talk about freaks those are the freaks
speaking of dangerous things
Megan rapino
who I am told as a soccer player Megan
rapino has a message for you
the message is that you need to go out
and get your 75th fauci ouchy and that
message
does not come free
get your booster here she is she's in
the doctor's office
okay she got her shot apparently
and then
you roll into the sheer let's go wait
let's go hey guys
so sad it's so cringy first of all
nobody thinks Megan Rubino is cool I
assume there are a handful of very sad
liberal people who tell themselves that
Megan rupino is cool and so this ad is
geared toward them but even Megan
rapino's heart is obviously not in it
so sad the way she's trying to say hey
y'all
Megan we're gonna get our Bubba Bubba
booster
cool let's roll but it's so happy
no one really believes it then you see
why it seems so contrived and
half-hearted
there's a little line right there at the
top of the Instagram post and it says
paid partnership
that's a weird paid partnership
who she partners with oh it tells you
the next line she's a Pfizer partner
#advisor partner like so many others one
of my New Year's resolutions is to focus
on my health and with the tournament
down down under coming up this year
it's more important than ever that I do
so that's why I got my updated covid-19
booster something I've been meaning to
check off my to-do list points for
prioritizing Health hashtag I'm boosted
go to vaccines.gov to check your
eligibility and schedule an appointment
today
so you you know this was just written by
the marketing department either in the
government or or Pfizer you know this
because she's using hashtags like it's
2008. that's enough people don't do that
anymore that's not but anyway so okay
I'm a hashtag I'm boosted hashtag Pfizer
partner I head on over to this
government website I've been meaning to
do this I feel really great
it's so important to go get your booster
you're so lucky to be able to have this
injection
if it's so great and if we're all so
lucky to be able to inject ourselves
with this experimental rug
why does Pfizer have to pay
Niche celebrities to promote it
if it's if it's so great
and if covet is so dangerous and scary
that we all were just waiting oh I can't
wait to get my vaccine why does Pfizer
why why does it government why does
whoever's footing the bill here
why do they have to pay it when
specifically why do they have to pay
this kind of celebrity
you know they're not calling me
they're not calling
Ben
they're not calling Tucker
and saying hey you want to be a Pfizer
partner because they know
and our audiences are going to say what
the hell is wrong with you people we're
not going to get that fouchy ouchy no no
clot shot for me thank you
no I'm good thanks
but
the handful of people who follow Megan
rapino that's the target audience they
know these Libs
these libs are at least going to be open
to getting the shot
and then what's so crazy is is even the
libs even even the very people who
follow Megan rapino
are not clamoring to go get the fauci
ouchy these are the people who should
have been the first in the line
and yet even they are not even they need
to be bribed
and bought off to get the shot I wonder
why that is probably because it's not a
great shot
well that's what I would deduce
speaking of the biomedical Security
State
the UN is going to take action against
me
for daring to question the genius of Dr
fauci and the benevolence of our rulers
in the lab coats the U.N Secretary
General is calling for Global action
against Miss and disinformation
will call for Action from everyone with
influence on the spread of means and
this information on the internet
governments Regulators policy makers
technology companies the media Civil
Society
stop the hate
set up strong guard rails be accountable
for language that causes harm
and as part of my report or common
agenda we are convening all stakeholders
around the code of conduct for
information Integrity on digital
platforms
and will also further strengthen our
focus on our means and this information
are impacting progress on global issues
including the climate crisis
the Miss and these information
and of course missing this information
just means anything that contradicts The
Narrative of the liberal Elite on any
given day so on the day where Dr fauci
said Don't wear a mask masks don't work
if you came out and said you should wear
a mask that would be missing
disinformation
but then five seconds later when Dr
fauci said actually you do need to wear
masks masks are very important masks do
work and you contradicted that and you
said actually you know I think masks
don't work that would be missing
disinformation the the the feature that
determines what the Miss and
disinformation is is just whatever the
Liberals are saying at this point and
you might say well who cares what the
U.N is warning about the U.N doesn't
have any power
the UN doesn't have a ton of power in
itself
but that's why the liberal Elites now
who are trying to censor what we can say
they're trying to go around the U.N
they're trying to even go around many of
the governments they're certainly trying
to go around the people they're trying
to build it into the platforms this is
the purpose of safety by Design which is
this proposal of the Australian e-safety
commissioner Julie Grant who's partnered
with the world economic Forum to get
this implemented around the world
because
what safety by Design says is Leia the
governments aren't going to really keep
up with all this stuff so we're just
going to embed our wokism into the the
speech platforms themselves then you've
only got to get it into three or four
speech platforms and all of a sudden the
libs can Implement their speech codes
their standards their taboos their
censorship at the drop of a head it'll
happen automatically from the platforms
that's happening right now and very very
powerful people are pushing for it
people more powerful perhaps even than
the US president President's Day is
coming up we used to call it
Washington's birthday because Washington
is a great man that we were celebrating
then we'd call it Washington's at
Lincoln's birthday we would celebrate
but now in our modern day and age we
call it President's Day and completely
changes the meaning of the holiday
because our nation is becoming very
uneducated and the libs are transforming
our culture
so this President's Day maybe you should
do something about it daily wire is
running our president's for sale sale
talking about our current president 40
off new annual memberships the big guy
got 10 we're giving you 40 get access to
the world of daily wire plus with
Fearless documentaries gripping movies
Dennis prager's master's program and the
entire library of Dr Jordan Peterson's
work including new productions Exodus
logos and literacy on marriage all
available to watch right now coming down
the pipeline to a TV or a laptop near
you new episodes of Ben Shapiro's the
search Exodus part 2 are much
anticipated DW kids content and
Pendragon later this year
to sweeten the deal like ice cream we
are also giving you up to 40 off select
items in the daily wire shop take
advantage of our president's for sale
sale today
you know he would go to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member that's
dailywire.com subscribe and in case you
missed it this past weekend I sat down
for another episode of yes or no the
internet's greatest interview and game
show with special guest Michael malis it
was great sitting down with Michael a
great guy with a great name it was a
riveting episode don't forget you can
bring the fun home with yes or no the
game it's available right now for
pre-order at dailywire.com shop
it's sold out when we ordered our first
run of I think a thousand games it sold
out fast there's a new run we've ordered
many multiples of that it's it's going
to sell out again so pre-order I think
there are still copies available
pre-order right now it's filled with
harmful and conspiracy content yes or no
tests your knowledge of those closest to
you do you really know your friends and
family do they really know you get to
the bottom of it all including your
glass with yes or no the game head on
over to dailywater.com shop to secure
yours today
got a lot of work to do over here to
save the West there was a book on this
topic that book is called
how to save the West It Is by a friend
of mine Spencer clay then absolutely no
relation to Andrew Clavin I am actually
writing a review of this book for the
Claremont Review of Books and when you
write a book review
you you go through a book and you
usually summarize the plot you give your
take on the information presented the
way in which it's presented the style of
the book The prose all of that and then
you list the things that the author
could have done better and I've I've
written plenty of book reviews and I
usually find all sorts of problems with
books and I'm I'm not exaggerating I
I did not have a criticism of this book
I was actually thinking do I need to
just make up a criticism just so my book
review doesn't look too positive that is
how good it is we are joined Now by my
friend Spencer live and Mr Clavin
welcome to the show
Michael my ears were burning hearing you
uh talk about that I was disappointed
that the review wasn't going to have
like you know the author's ears are too
big or something in there because I just
think that would be good well I was
thinking as a little addendum to the
review to say you know look my praise of
the book notwithstanding the author is a
big fat dumb stupid idiot but but I
don't know I ran out of words by the end
so it is I hate to say it you know it's
men and especially buddies especially
long time buddies it's it feels very
strange to just give a sincere
compliment it feels that's not how men
talk to one another but it's very
squishy and weird yeah it is squishy and
weird and I feel like a big lib uh it's
just so good and I I actually I went
into the book
thinking okay I now I see a little way
that I could criticize it because the
book opens up and it's talking about
things that are really present they're
very urgent kind of modern things that
you would see in the headlines and I
said okay this is going to be one of
these just okay Spencer's going to cover
the news and then
just very quickly you tie the the things
that we're seeing around us right now
into
polybius and Plato and Aristotle and
then you come right back up to Kendrick
Lamar and then you come to and it's and
it's so seamless and it's so you
actually finish the book and you say oh
this guy is not just showing off his
scholarship and oh this guy is not just
riffing on the news this guy has an
Urgent Message for what to do about a
civilization that that feels as though
it's not only in Ruins but but still has
some pieces of the marble about to fall
down on our heads
you know it's really perceptive and
thanks for saying that this is a book
that is based on the radical idea that
the past has something to say to the
present and that's basically it that's
the simple claim which is not so simple
anymore since as you were just talking
about earlier in the show the the very
idea of Western Civilization that we
might be inheritors of a tradition
carriers of a flame that comes down from
these kind of two uh Central
civilizations Athens and Jerusalem this
whole notion is portray paid regularly
in the news as somehow primitive it's
superstitious it's maybe it kind of
racially chauvinist people make all
sorts of accusations you're a racist
you're a sexist for talking about those
dumb old guys and one of the things that
I try to do in this book is just say
look you know every day we wake up we
see some news story that makes us feel
like everything's falling apart and it's
really easy to think that all of this is
just the result of you know rapidly
accelerating technology and science has
transformed the world and of course
those things may be true but what the
book is about is a lot of the questions
that were coming up against are actually
extremely fundamental they've been with
Humanity basically ever since we were on
this planet and there are some really
rich uh answers to these questions that
are available from the tradition if
you'll just look and you know they're
they do everything they can to try and
convince you not to do that they tell
you that these books are outdated that
they're bad that they're evil that
Aristotle was some kind of you know you
the chauvinist racist whatever
um all to prevent you from understanding
that the answers to questions like why
am I here what's my place in the
universe what's a human being um these
questions that we're grappling with now
you will find better sane or clearer
more Humane answers in some of these
texts that the book deals with than you
will from like Dr fauci and whatever
modern you know un Guru is supposed to
be in charge of us today so that's
exactly the point of the book it's just
as you said you know I've got about 30
seconds left in the main portion of the
show for the Hoy polloi out there who
have not yet gone over to dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles And subscribe
you you say in the subtitle it's ancient
wisdom for five modern crises what are
the modern crises
I'll list them off and then I'll say a
little bit about them the first is the
crisis of reality is anything true or
false the second is the crisis of the
body do our unique human forms have
anything to say about us or should they
just be replaced re-engineered uh
transformed with gender surgery
um the third is the crisis of meaning
can we really believe that anything has
any meaning Beyond just the mere fact of
evolution and and replication and this
leads directly into the deepest crisis
which I think is the crisis of religion
can we believe in a Creator God that has
an interest in us that's the most
important question before us and I
answer it in the affirmative yes we can
before turning to the crisis of the
regime which is the most immediate one
what's going on in America what's going
to happen to us and can we survive I
want you to give us I want you to give
us the answers to that but I don't want
you to give it to the Hoy polloi these
freeloaders who they show up I
appreciate that they show up but they
don't want to Fork over
the their hard-earned money because I
don't know they want to go buy eggs or
something like that which is impossible
and you never you're never going to
afford eggs these days uh if you want to
watch the answers and if you want to
come chat with us over the member Block
You've got to head over to dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knolls at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign